[Music]
if your guyses teacher dressed up in a
dress oh do you think you'd be a lot
less stressed if you had to take off the
SATs or something not make me horny Oh a
male oh I'd be confused wait what if
that's how they normally dress that's
fine but if there's a new I'll be like
like the purpose is to make you less
stress why would that let me distract
the [ __ ] out of me cuz it's like a
hilarious distraction clearly upset but
and then are they telling us like hey
I'm doing this because I'm trying to
make you less this oh it depends like
even more like curious about it I'm
thinking about that madness into you cuz
imagine like you play in the NBA right
and it's gonna be the finals the amp
that'd be ready to [ __ ] play this
last game and the referee comes out in
the 2-2 you're like wait what it's gonna
catch you off guard like a [ __ ]
it would totally depend on the context
of who that teacher is like if that
teacher also showed up previously in the
year in like dinosaur outfits or like
cow onesies or you know it's different
yeah then I'm like okay this is mr. blah
blah blahs way of yeah but this this is
like the first thing that we've ever
witnessed
of course it's distract yeah yeah relax
me that's my that's the thought process
let me just wear something more
nurturing maybe that's what the thought
method is you know like it's like a
muumuu yeah like like how does that like
just seeing him and playing closes why
is that intimidating like in the first
place it's breaking the ice
kinda like patch Adams like in the Robin
Williams movie yeah where everyone's all
like serious and it goes on and they're
like oh it's not that bad being a
hospital but you wouldn't break the ice
on your last day of school
okay what's not breaking the ice it's
more like like lightening up the mood
because racing
yeah if I was when I was a girl actually
I'm kinda nervous for the date and I'm
like oh I got something I show up with
an address do you think that's gonna
make it less like see that would be like
that's weird
I've seen a demon address you have where
you've dressed in a dress do I have any
public comment
what's in the closet right now like are
we talking about miniskirt like wedding
dress yeah we're like wedding dress
we're like prong down is there a photo
cocktail I want to see you know way like
a randomly attractive male that looks
like a good female or just like a buff
dude you know what I mean okay so back
either way it's great all right so backs
are here at this high school teacher in
China has gone viral for let like for
probably looks good a dress
yeah for showing up to support his
students taking the like their national
like exam like exit exam rotor well
national college entrance examination
okay see that's a stressful time he
showed up in a keep how Oh like a
traditional dress I'll read this little
excerpt so laughing keep out which
became popular in the 1920s and 30s is
typically worn by mothers of students
taking the exam they believe it brings
good luck to test takers as the sling on
the side of the dress is called keep
Powell oh yeah there's a slip into in
Mandarin it sounds similar to the phrase
I'm not even gonna try to say it but it
translates to success on the first try
that's it ah okay ki kya Shang ke Kai
dishing I don't know look at how you
just Chinese enough let me repeat
Cantonese tones it's written cognition
oh that's the one
I relieve my stress keep house actually
cheap huh
cheap cheap ow she likes each she - Paul
she like cheesy I yeah I was watching
this travel vlogger and I found another
one that liked to travel and in the
Philippines and stuff and he was on the
street and there are these like pretty
ladies and then they're like oh you
sisters are fight and like hot and then
she's like we are brothers
and then in the comments it was like
well if they're brothers that I have to
question my sexuality right now because
they were hot they were subra they were
handsome
what was this the Philippines oh yeah
they were like satellite Thailand they
look like they're going to the to the
club and any like oh you sisters are hot
and they're like we are brothers let me
see this photo yeah the video oh honey
I'll find this teacher is so fine are
you ready don't get motor I'm sitting
right next to you it's already come up
and like cut the dress that's like the
most human thing I've ever seen the
Asian teacher do yeah ding they just try
to relax everyone that's pretty cool
mm-hmm then did he walk around during a
test with a stick to hit people heard I
had a very different image in my head
but I'm very pleased with this one he
saw that he was gonna have a wig that
well like culturally that makes sense
too and it's kind of funny I was
thinking like our American teacher just
shows a brown minute dress be like I
hope this like that's what else that's
not nothing it was like mr. Rogers
wearing like a prom dress yeah yeah Bill
Nye the Science Guy in a [ __ ] Vegas
club outfit like platform heels I know
I'm very sweet yeah
nice teacher just relax everybody your
life not over if you fail but really is
over it's like when you are when you
apparently apparently go on stage and
you get nervous so you know people tell
you to imagine everybody's like in their
underwear and you get horny I thought
everyone did love that yeah but yeah I
could understand that too I know that's
a saying but does anyone actually try to
that like has that ever helped you know
what helps me is if I stand to the light
or if I just dare one person I talked to
one percenter yeah I mean now now
because we've done it so much it's like
natural but like in the beginning it's
like yeah I like I just stare into the
light so I don't see anybody or you talk
to a person out of town talk like
in-between the people if you just talk
to one person you just focus on them
like do they ever fall in love with you
bar because you're making like constant
eye contact with them Julia that's
ridiculous my dudes fall in love with me
you can't find romance anyplace dudes I
want to hang out with me after the shows
yeah yeah it's mainly the guys you
really think that I think that's working
like you just staring at one person and
only solely talking to them it's like
you're speaking to my best not that I'm
against this Julia breaking the heart
against this heavily because during Jake
amy is like for some reason my eyes
always go to Bart and just easier to
just talk to Bart even though you guys
are all here like I don't agree with
this logic why is that angle so easy to
look at and talking to me - yeah you
know maybe it's magnificant think what
I'm telling the story I end up being
like just it's true though in order to
live gotta go like this yeah that's
right
yeah people think I'm rude cuz I never
look left yeah so I have to really work
this way but not an Ambu Turner well cuz
the news is being told this way it's
like look left I can't even go that turn
you can't turn left you're next you're
next you still know it's cuz my my body
is faced this way because I'm listening
to the news a point of focus is
typically right in a so much I do the
easiest for you
I don't know how to explain that though
because one time you and geo switch
seats and I still was looking at you it
wasn't even that cheo cheo told me is
that I reciprocate what someone's
telling me a lot you noticed
so as you're telling me like I'm really
engaged and I think because of that like
it's easy to talk to me because I'm
Martin gage because I'm not like a poker
face book so some people also get
intimidated because I'm like I'll look
at you and then you'll be like so lies
get distracted to something it's like
two laser pointer to sort of follow each
other action like I'm trying to make a
connection here but I don't know what
you're looking at I mean even though you
guys are listening not everyone really
gives me eye contact the way Bart does
so maybe that's true ice look into the
ether when I speak or even as you're
listening like right now you see you're
not looking at me
sometimes I'll stare at the beam and
then I'm listening to frickin Anthony
and I'm like yeah I know but I mean Doug
doesn't usually give eye contact to
people anyway like they are those true
you've gotten a lot better over the
years though I don't like to look at
people's eyes it's like I'm stealing
your soul and I don't want to do that
I'm trying to know why like when talking
to girls like girls is different I'll
look I know be more into girls that I'm
hunting I will look into their eyes I
think his eyes just widened slightly
he's like hunting predator
I got a predator a sexual predator in a
in a legal way okay not an illegal way
okay I'm a sexual predator in a legal
please wha me way uh no you're like the
was the hunter and then yeah right pray
he's like the prey but he's trying to
get them to hunt him yeah yeah that's
all yeah it was just a cool name that's
got some really bad branding so let's
just leave it at that
let's not use the word predator let's
use the word pursuer sexual pursuer how
about that
I think throwing sexual before it is
actually part of the problem respectful
you sound like a manipulator creepy okay
well okay how about respectfully sexual
manipulator or something oh I got it
how about for seeing interest asking for
consent first in sexual encounters so
like consensually disrespecting her body
no why would I disrespect Oh like hard
sex No
so super horny and lustful okay guy I
got it I got it all right it's a mutual
sexual negotiation negotiation that
that's it's a mutual sexual negotiator
sound very passionate prostitution oh
yeah
it also sounds like that okay what about
well how would you say like one step
under lovemaking is that what you're
looking for like pursuing someone in
your tribe there is a word and you're
trying to hoard it I forgot what it's
called like a shooter like a suitor kind
of person isn't it just you're it's a
perfect game god damn it professional
seducer yeah but that sounds like a male
escort
does your lady like a Salesman you're
the prostitute selling your own body to
them and see if they want to buy it
respectful ho no I'm trying really
enticing enticing you just say you're a
we were all right I'm a lure
so I stare into the eyes of my would
wear my lose that
[Music]